hey youtubers is Charlie huge news the
flash arrow and legends of tomorrow were
all renewed for new seasons so let's
talk about what's going to happen next
the real surprise is that the CW renewed
every single series that it has with two
exceptions and the only reason there are
two shows that it did not renew is
because they haven't premiered yet this
season every other show that it renewed
is either in the middle of its season or
has just started like legends of
tomorrow so I'm mostly going to be
talking about flash stuff in this video
I'll do a separate arrow video probably
this weekend I haven't done an arrow
trailer video in a little while so I'll
talk about it then because even though
arrow the flash in legends of tomorrow
all share the same universe they cross
over a lot they're all going to have
their separate storylines although I do
think that in a future season like
whenever one of these shows gets ready
to end if they want to live dangerously
or maybe they start taking a bunch of
drugs they might try to do some big
storyline that crosses over all three
shows but we got to talk about what's
happening on the flash now for season
three we haven't even got to the end of
season two so we don't know how they're
going to resolve this zoom storyline
obviously they're going to have to stop
him somehow there are a number of
different comic book ways they could do
that but each season they tend to go a
little off comic book so it's kind of
hard to predict I think a trap zoom in
the speedforce and if they're spinning
in some edward clariss Golden Age
reverse flash stuff they could have him
turn into pure energy that's kind of
what happened to the edward clariss
reverse flash in the comics when the
flash chased him down for the last time
he ran so fast that he became pure
energy but then later materialized out
of the Speed Force and inhabited the
body of max mercury I do think that
we'll see a version of max mercury on
the show sometime in the future we have
mercury labs
we'll have to see max mercury at some
point but because they spend so much
time setting up earth-2 during season
two I think without them completely
recycling the plot lines from season two
will continue to see a lot of earth-2
villains in season three but as was the
case with season one of the flash to
season two I think season two - season
three he'll try to mine some new big
area to surface villains from so we're
talking gorilla City things that they
only tease during season two if you guys
missed it I did a video earlier this
week about how I think they might end
the flash but that's after season 7
season 8 like the very last episode of
the flash that they ever make where he
becomes the bolt of light
that gave him powers in between that you
have season 3 season 4 season 5 and so
on so they need different villains what
is the next villain that they could do
well for this I'm actually going to make
a lateral move to arrow because Marc
Guggenheim tweeted at me like this
little funny comment when I was like hey
why don't we make Donald Trump the
villain for arrow season 5 and he was
just being funny but he said too
ridiculous but he was also being a
little truthful because the villains on
arrow need to be based in reality
so really the joke was about Donald
Trump being even crazier than a
comic-book villain the villain needs to
be believable which is why it's really
hard to do cosmic big bads like Darkseid
even the anti-monitor is just completely
unrealistic at this point the bonus that
the flash has working for it is that
they can do powers so you can actually
do some pretty fantastic stuff that you
might not be able to do on arrow but
there are a couple story devices that I
would like to see them do at some point
like the black racer the problem with
doing the black racer who's kind of like
the personification of death for the
speedsters is that they did a villain
with a black suit this season so one
that's a strike against that and - the
idea of the flash fighting against his
own death literally fighting against his
own death is almost too fantastic you
want a physical villain that you can
actually reach out and touch and whose
motivation also flows from the same
logic that is driving the hero during
that season so we haven't got to the end
of the zoom storyline so there's a lot
of things that we still don't know about
him but you could think about it this
way
Barry's big search this season is to
find happiness in spite of what the
reverse-flash told them no matter how
much you win you'll never be happy and
Barry's like if that I will totally find
happiness zoom is probably also looking
for happiness we don't know why but as
far as we know his happiness is derived
from being the fastest speedster so he's
searching for more and more speed trying
to take it from the flash now so it's
too soon to tell what Barry is going to
be searching for in season 3 like what
his own internal conflict is going to be
but whatever the villain is it's also
going to flow from that same logic so
it's probably going to be another human
villain and because we're only in season
3 I do think that they'll try to use
another speedster or a twist on another
speedster I wouldn't be surprised if by
the time we get to arrow season 4 though
if they decide to go with their very
first big bag that is not a speedster
the please oh please
at some point I would love to see the
flash where this comic book suit that he
wears when he becomes the god of death
so I'm going to explain how he got this
suit just careful for spoilers from
Justice League dark side war what you're
looking at here probably the most badass
version of a flash suit that we've ever
seen what happened in the comics is that
the anti-monitor got into a fight with
Darkseid
he goaded Darkseid in to summoning the
black racer the aspect of death to kill
the anti-monitor for him but then the
anti-monitor who has the anti-life
equation flowing in his veins he is
literally the embodiment of death forces
the black racer whose powers are derived
from death to merge with Barry Allen so
Barry Allen becomes the new host for
death he becomes the new god of death
already you can see exactly why the
flash TV show cannot do this it is way
too crazy and they haven't even done any
of the new gods yet which I would
totally love to see them do on a TV show
they could do a couple of the minor ones
I think they're saving the big ones for
the movies though but let me know in the
comments who do you want to see be the
big villain for the flash season 3
without really knowing how the flash
season 2 is going to end so I know a lot
of you want to see Eddie come back and
be the villain of a future season the
problem with that I'll say right off the
bat is that Quantico the TV show that he
is a main cast member on just got
renewed for a new season
Eddie will be back in this season though
in a flashback but that episode won't be
happening for a while so remove Eddie
from the equation and just think of any
other character that you might want I
would love to see a version of Beck's
mercury I'm not expecting the villain to
come from earth 2 because the villain
from season 2 came from earth 2 so
that's kind of redundant so here's the
thing if each new season of the flash is
about cranking the crazy way up think
about a villain manifesting directly
from the Speed Force because we've
already done the wolf in sheep's
clothing coming from the future we've
clothing coming from earth-2
what is the other kind of villain that
they could do and they've already done
the thing where a friend turns into a
villain or a friend is secretly
masquerading as a villain so I'm not
expecting danielle Panabaker from earth
1 to become killer frost and be the big
bad at season 3 like the next step up on
the ladder of crazy would be to have the
Speed Force itself manifest a villain
and you're really talking edward clariss
in the body of
mercury but that does kind of sound like
eobard thawne in the body of Harrison
wells so whatever they end up doing I
think it's going to be really hard for
them to do something that's completely
unique that they haven't done before but
giveaway time congratulations to this
week's DC giveaway winner flaming
guitars you win a $20 Amazon gift card
be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so and get your
contact details if you don't know how to
do that it's the message tool on the
about page one of these days I think I'm
gonna have to re-explain how all the
giveaways work because there's so many
new people so many of you guys are new
on the channel and I'm so happy but they
just means there's probably like a lot
of people who have no idea how the
giveaways work so no worries there why
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for my Captain
America civil war trailer
yay spider-man so happy that he's here
and you can click here for my arrow
brave bonus video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight